[Music]
he goes
back and stick face
[Music]
don't break don't break don't
break so at the end you lose your your
thrusting intention okay so I'll go even
though I know I'm going to miss I keep
my mind in the
thrust then I come back and I still have
a
projection I'm not going like this
thrust and now now I'm not now I'm on
and then I come back okay so work on
your singular intention I'm and I
thrust and I'm holding
it and then I'm holding the threat in
[Music]
tension okay so you good
you it's not there it's my throat's not
there you do you understand no yeah my
throat is not that high my throat is
this
[Music]
high so look how I'm
here and there's a brace to my arm you
see that don't try to move their sword
[Music]
okay just
C he goes watch this Ang
response do you see
that make your sword nothing it goes
around his
sword it sticks to his
[Music]
sword he's going to ski I stay on the
line and he goes and look at my weight
shift that's
enough that's all I need so what am I
shifting my weight to his body body
moving no weight on that front foot at
that
point boom
okay let's
go so this is the old thing of I right
so if I have plus pressure it's not
I if I have minus pressure it's not iy
and then the blades don't stick there's
no communion and a blade that's not
stuck to my blade is a blade that it's
not under my control okay so it's just a
very simple drill
maintain let's get back there you
go so not like this no I was I was a
minus right not like this
no just try to keep zero zero pressure
on the on the weapon very little little
I'm not doing anything with my hands I
just letting him move you can see my
sword is spinning in my grip from his
his sword is rolling
me so all I'm doing in the technique is
not letting my sword Shin but my sword
is stuck to
his okay try it
all right so my technique here
as you get is I'm trying to get as much
violence of action under that
thrust it's no different from Bo just
running at him to tackle him or take him
down or I'm throwing a barage of punches
and kicks get him going backwards got it
get him on the defense you understand
okay so when I do my my ski I have to
have that
and you're going to practice that
singular
intention throw your sword
out okay let's go it right
[Music]
making my sword just
disappear it's extremely light
right okay let's go
and see so when I'm on this side of his
weapon and his weapon can't go from
where it is to my direction do you get
that he has to do other things like
maybe back up and come on the other side
you
see well in this case a guy's running at
you it's extremely common it's a
fantastic tactic just charge the guy
most people are going to fold under the
aggression they will
that's why the solution to this is not
you you think you're in the fight you
already lost the
fight you're just going to go Yin he's
going to push and you're going to go Yin
and you're going to take advantage of
what now becomes not violence of action
but uh over penetration I made it over
penetration the yin space did was had I
tried to fight him perfect penetration
right
so as my weapon is coming here we'll go
even slower when can when does the
stomach open happen doesn't happen here
you see he can come and get
me so I have to allow for his hands to
go by do you see that we'll do it on
this
side when his when when his hands are
past me that is the when right there
when I can do it
hi I don't want to unstick my sword here
you see that you guys see that and just
the way nature works when his hands are
going to pass you boom that's where
you'll feel that his sword doesn't have
anything on it anymore there's a Yin
void there and it'll give you the
opening now when you go faster it's just
like all things things if you if you're
looking for when his hands are there and
then you're going to decide to move
you're going to be late you understand
so you have to have your kinesthetic
awareness of I'm going to move now
because as I move now that's when his
hands are going to be there you
understand so probably to you it's going
to feel like you're going earlier but
some of you are going way early okay
it'll you want to instead feel when it
is
feel when your sword can just be free of
his and it'll fall into that
spot so again you'll you'll see how
light I'm not holding my sword because
it's never really challenged At All by
him just let it fall into the spots
[Music]
I'm not going like
this can you see that difference okay
try
it when we do like for example the uh
the bait for the side
control Okay so
he got my arm stuck outside right and I
bait him with the High Bridge he pushes
back and then I take him now here's
where a lot of you will start to roll
him do you see that and what we want
instead is that we move ourselves see
that that is
jiujitsu same thing here you're not
picking up his sword and giv the
opening he will feel that he will feel
this is not going as planned okay so
we're going to go slower you're going to
see how I'm changing my
height I move
myself okay if for some reason you feel
your target is closing and you need more
opening Move Yourself
he picks it
[Music]
up my sword's going under
hit okay let's go
So Pro proving strike so I'll
be I'm here back off back
in back off back you might do your
second you might do the the second one
so I probe and then I
charge okay so we'll just standardize it
so one step ski come off and reacquire
the new line of attack okay
go and I'm just sticking with this with
this
[Music]
movement nothing
stick to his sword like your life
dependent on it you
[Music]
see so I'm not fighting there I'm
fighting the Archer so I'm dealing with
his
body okay let's
go boom and you'll feel
it then you take the off cuz he's going
in
right he goes young I go y
slower my sword is nothing and when my
sword goes around him I'm not lifting
his sword let let the energy free your
sword okay even that was
bad that's better I'm trying not to move
his sword left to
right okay not till I attack the hands
in subba
so my spirit my tactics Are Yin and Yang
but my spirit is
centered I've neither push nor pull and
I neither push nor pull
and the sword requires no strength is
just fitting in all of its Yin
spaces he goes a little
faster a little
faster one more my sword
disappear okay let's try
it okay so on this rolling cut as I come
around here wait stay there I'm not
going to go early hi do you see hi it's
it's it's the same mistake of he's doing
the violence of action charge and I'm
starting to cut here you you the sword
is available to get
you and the second thing is as you go
it's not just a hand attack so hold your
sword up okay and come off the wall and
I'm not I'm just going to show you the
vectors that I'm using okay so here I
going down you see that and then watch
this other Vector
here do you see that yes so one vector
you're here you you put your atoshi here
yes and the other atoshi you put boom
into his
Center so and we start looking obviously
I want to take his balance
right so as he goes what's what's going
to give me that Vector well if I don't
move in with him I'm not going to get it
right so that's why we did that one
trans that one drill where I walked with
him you see I'm walk I can walk with him
and now I'm doing that same drill but
I'm doing it with right adashi so I go
here and I go here right you see
that and that gives me that
Vector into his Center so his Center is
getting manipulated even if I don't
knock him down I will check him out
temporarily you understand and boom what
determines how much you knock him down
is how much his Center comes forward
just like for example he's here right
and I have X range on my punch right and
I'm only allowed y uh closing of the Gap
that's all the penetration I'm going to
again do you understand but if I let him
into here then that's a different level
of penetration do you see that so how
much kazushi you get has to do with this
first move of
Disappearing because that pulls him in
you understand okay try it